bonjour je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point particulier du cerveau dans les
épisodes précédents vous nous avez
proposé d'aborder les biais cognitifs
c'est le sujet du jour
bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
on rit
je suis
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une tous
biaisé expérience de lecture de penser
expérience 3 le grand test collectif
expérience 4c d'offres le tout avec la
présence très appréciée de simon astier
il est presque certain que vous avez
déjà tous entendu parler des biais
cognitif quelque chose de biaiser c'est
quelque chose qui va pas droit d'un côté
qui est biaisé lorsqu'une information
subi un biais cognitif
alors elle est biaisé c'est à dire que
les détourner quel est malaxé cac perd
son sens initial et du coup notre
raisonnement est erroné
c'est le biais d'optimisme qui par
exemple dans le cadre d'une épidémie
fait qu'on se sent moins à risque que
les autres et donc qu'on va prendre un
peu moins ces précautions que les autres
et pourtant dans le même temps on va
être capable d'être très critique envers
d'autres personnes qui ne prennent pas
les précautions qu'il faudrait comme
nous c'est le cas par exemple de
l'utilisation du préservatif qui oblige
à des campagnes de sensibilisation
régulière les magiciens qui ont pour
métier de tromper notre cerveau utilise
les biais cognitif pour nous illusionner
avec notre consentement et ça c'est ce
qu'on va voir maintenant
évidemment c'est les magiciens qui
utilisent le mieux les biais cognitif
des fois sans le savoir parce qu'ils ont
besoin de tromper le cerveau et donc par
la force des choses et par l'expérience
ils ont compris des trucs je vais faire
un tour hyper classique il ya un docteur
en psychologie albert mokhiber il a
sorti un livre qui s'appelle votre
cerveau vous joue des tours
il a référencé comme ça des torts très
classique qui fonctionne et qui sont des
bonnes bases de connaissances pour mieux
les comprendre
le tour est hyper simple il ya quelques
cartes et je te demande d'en retenir une
et une seule es tu me dis quand on a une
en tête
oui tu as fait ton choix ouais ok
regardez moi un plaisir je vais enlever
une je fais je fais un choix mais je
pense que c'est elle je la pose sous le
paquet comme ça je peux pas je veux pas
la perdre
je pense que c'est parce est que ta
carte en tout cas c'est celle que j'ai
enlevé est ce que tu vas toujours ta
carte
non
donc ces prochains temps réussi c'est
parce qu'on valide et validé par les
biais cognitif
j'ai pas du tout enlever ta carte enfin
pas vraiment j'ai bien enlever une carte
mais c'est pas forcément la tienne en
fait j'ai enlevé toutes les cartes que
tu as vu au départ c'est pas du tout le
même set de cartes maintenant que le
sais tu que tu as eu au début et ça m'a
c'était laquelle de takhar nice était
seul à la dame de trèfle a été remplacé
simplement par la dame de pique et en
fait tu as vécu ce qu'on appelle un
biais de sélection et un biais de
confirmation
c'est à dire que tu n'as chercher que ce
qu'ils correspondaient à ton choix et
donc ça a confirmé pour toi que j'avais
réussi puisque ton choix n'était pas là
et ça c'est un biais cognitif hyper
classique qui est la source des
discriminations et du racisme par
exemple parce qu'on va chercher toujours
les infos qui correspondent à ce qu'on
croit nous et on le voit avec ce tour de
magie
est-ce que tu remets ta vie en question
sinon à wes a commencé par court mais
aurait bien déjouer
le biais de sélection et de confirmation
était utilisé dans le premier tour car
nous cherchons la carte que nous avions
choisi pour confirmer son absence et
c'est ce raisonnement qui nous a donné
l'illusion que le tour avait fonctionné
ce biais est dangereux quand il s'agit
de nos opinions 40 du coup on va voir
spontanément tendance à aller chercher
de l'information qui conforte nos
opinions de base le biais de sélection
et de confirmation est malheureusement
souvent à l'origine des discriminations
du racisme etc
avant de passer à la suite je vous
rappelle que cette vidéo est sponsorisé
par parce qu'on sort qu'en matière grise
donc pas toujours par moi même pourquoi
on est en colère déjà parce qu'on vient
de payer les impôts
bon on n'a qu'à écrire un livre on
pourrait faire un tour de table avec
tout le monde on trouve le sujet et il
est où bonheur on peut pas le faire si
l'apa bonheur il n'est jamais là sud
c'est là dessus qu'on devrait écrire un
livre je suis sûr que fabien il a plein
de trucs à dire sur le bonheur et puis
les chèque qui se porte toujours aussi
con honneur est caché dans un coin de
votre cerveau c'est mon nouveau livre
qui est sorti le 24 septembre dans
toutes les librairies dans les fnac dans
les cultures à sur internet et ça traite
principalement du bonheur il n'y a pas
trop de surprises mais surtout de
l'échec de la flexibilité mentale de la
réussite et de toute ma vie que j'ai dû
mettre un petit peu à nu pour vous dire
qu'on pouvait changer son rapport à
l'échec et son rapport au bonheur
voici une étude très étonnant qui a eu
lieu en 2006 en allemagne
on a demandé à des juges de faire un
exercice très simple de lire le compte
rendu d'un vol à l'étalagé hyper
classique un peu plus tard on a demandé
à ces mêmes juges de lancer de dés mais
les dés étaient complètement qui paie et
le résultat obtenu était forcément 3 ou
9 toujours un peu plus tard on a demandé
à ces mêmes juges de prononcer une
sentence pour le vol à l'étalagé
on leur disait combien de mots de prison
pour le voleur les juges qui ont obtenu
9 des ont donné en moyenne huit mois de
prison comme sentence les juges qui ont
obtenu 3 odéon donnait en moyenne cinq
mois 200 ans pour le voleur évidemment
ça c'est à cause d'un billet et c'est le
biais d' ancrage le biais d'un ancrage
est tellement fort qu'il fonctionne sur
des juges qui ont pourtant 15 ans
d'expérience et dont l'image du résultat
d'aidé n'apportant rien à voir avec le
vol à l'étalagé a compris le concept
c'est que quand tu as une idée ou un
raisonnement en fait appartient pas
vraiment c'est tout ce que tu as vécu
dans ta vie qui fait que ça prend des
raccourcis pour plein de raisons
différentes parce qu'il faut décider
mais il faut agir vite et ça ça vient
d'eux quand on était à la préhistoire de
se dire j'ai mangé un champignon rouge
j'étais malade du coup tout des
champignons rouge je vais faire gaffe
ont fait des raccourcis de cerveau tu
vois j'ai envie d'essayer un truc avec
toi c'est un truc que j'ai vu à la
télévision le soir tard ce faire je suis
dit 'tiens georges massimo ont fait ça
ensemble
il faudrait qu'ils fassent un choix dans
ta tête que tu penses 1
un édifice n'importe quel édifice en
fait en france connu assez connu en tout
cas portent le connaissent et d'une
manière d'une construction relativement
récente
c'est pas des pyramides d'égypte et par
exemple ne sont pas du tout en france en
plus pour le du coup tu choisi voilà à
l'édifice construction relativement
récente quelque part en france qui me
dit pas lequel évidemment es tu me dis
quand t'es ok récente ça veut dire quoi
pas très lointaine dans le temps c'était
on peut on peut s'offrir deux cents ans
ok ou 300 ans
mais ça peut être un immeuble connu sa
pluie voilà exactement un portail connu
par exemple le jouet donc mon choix de
monuments et fait donc ils changent
je rigole c'est juste le psg ou sortie
qui avait pas eu un grand choix de vins
grands de chiba oui parce que oui ok ce
monument dédié à peu près ce que je
perçois et j'expliquerai après comment
tu vas à temps mais parce que je crois
que j'ai changé entre le moment où j'ai
choisi où tu mets des échanges et beige
change alors j'ai changé
ok tu veux rechange et jean marais de
convier ouais je leur ai dit si ces mots
je le vis et du coup ce que je pensais
c'est plus bon alors c'est ça qui est
sensible envers toi ok non mais on garde
le deuxième le deuxième le deuxième
comme ça si ça marche pas j'ai une bonne
excuse pour moi assez spontanément j'ai
un truc d'eau autour ou à côté
est-ce que ça parle j'ai une source
d'eau pas loin parce que n'ai je pas ce
qu'elle passait le lieu est encore ok
j'ai quelque chose
de très clair d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup
de clarté des espaces dans la structure
comme un espèce de eu un verset pas là
de triomphe non plus mais on est quand
même sur tu vois quelque chose d'arrondi
à l'envers j'en arrondi très présent
beaucoup d'activités beaucoup de
mouvements autour ans j'ai les couleurs
bleu et rouge peut-être au-dessus
est ce que ça te parle ça ou c'est moi
dans ma tête alors c'est toute la
complexité le truc c'est que ça me parle
sur un des deux que j'ai choisi ok
est-ce que tout match plus sur l'un des
deux ouais ah ok donc je suis sûr
premier ses frais ok d'accord et c'est
quoi le premier du coup c'est beau bourg
et c'est beau bourg et donc on a tout
faux on dit aux gens de personnes
passage en atout donc je t'écris beau
pour ce qui est déjà pas si mal un g2
respect ok maintenant on veut parler de
ça en fait ça c'est patrick froment
qu'un autre mentalist qui a écrit un
livre que je connais bien et il a
référencé un truc à la télévision qui
est juste dingue c'est un voyant qu'ils
devinent des monuments dans une
enveloppe à un moment donné ils ont fait
ce test pour voir la fiabilité de sa
voyance ce que je t'ai dit c'est
exactement ce qu'il a dit ni plus ni
mois à est en fait patrick forme en
faisant un peu de recherche s'est aperçu
que pour tous les monuments relativement
récent en france connue d'un peu tout le
monde
la plupart de ces éléments-là match
quand et comment ça se fait que ça
fonctionne du coup parce que il ya les
chefs horreur votre moi pelé l'effet
barnum qui fait que des généralités ou
des choses vague tu vas te les
approprier pour que ça colle à quelque
chose moi je sais pas de quoi je t'ai
parlé je t'ai répéter ce que disait le
voyant en fait mais si tu avais choisi
la tour tf1
en fait il ya de la clarté l'activité
autour qui a de loin côté avec la scène
il ya le bleu et rouge en haut il y a
tout fonctionne lui un ver situe le col
ou tu veux mais si tu prends la tour
eiffel lui eut inversé dans le voit
aussi dans le bas et de l'activité des
genres tour le tour le bus rouge du bleu
blanc rouge
ah oui oui d'avancé au caire est le leaf
et barbelés fait les foreurs il est un
peu où c'est ce qui fait que les
horoscopes fonctionne par exemple on
peut croire en l'astrologie ça c'est pas
le problème mais en tout cas on y croit
ou pas on va toujours ramené à ce qu'on
connaît de nous-mêmes pour rire quand
même incroyable ça parce qu'il a dit
exactement ce que j'avais dans la tête
et en poussant un petit peu avec des
lieux communs c'est un truc qu'on
utilise beaucoup en mentalisme cold
reding on peut donner le sentiment à la
personne d'avoir lu sa pensée alors
qu'on n'a rien dit on peut lui faire
même donné la réponse sans qu'il s'en
rende compte pour la réutiliser 15
minutes plus tard il ya et du coup je
pense que tu penses à et la personne
apple en ratissant large oui en coupant
des éléments vague mais évocateur
on peut trouver n'importe quoi c'est
vrai moi je préfère une séance de
voyance comme ça de ça je moi je perçois
juste une douleur à un moment mais
c'était vraiment il ya des années et ça
a été une trahison pour toi des fois
encore qu'ils repensent même ça tu as
construit un peu différemment parce que
tu dis ok maintenant je vais être un peu
plus dur mais au fond de toi tu sais que
ça pas complètement guérie tu vois ça
fait partie des lits et l'on peut
c'est très bien quand on prétend savoir
des choses sur vous demandez toujours
des détails de sa demande est toujours
un peu plus de confirmation de choses
comme ça de ne donnait pas la réponse
avant l'autre parce que sachez que votre
cerveau a besoin de donner de la
cohérence et du sens à tous il a
toujours recherché il voit un numéro de
train s'il ya une date de naissance
dedans il va dire mais c'est fou quand
même parce que ça c'est quand même le
train qui est important et j'ai vu ma
date de naissance dedans c'est quand
même un signe non c'est un train là
vraiment
voici un autre genre de biais l'effet
barnum ou encore l'effet foreurs ce
biais force notre cerveau à accepter
quelque chose de vague de général comme
étant quelque chose de personnel à nous
tout à l'heure votre cerveau a cherché à
donner du sens entre ce que nous disions
est ce que vous pensiez pour que tout
soit cohérent cet effet de validation
subjectif et d'ailleurs ce qui est
reproché au médium et au voyant le
meilleur moyen d'étudier un biais
cognitif est encore de le démontrer sur
un groupe plusieurs études ont été
réalisées sur le sujet et des
documentaires ont même été fait en
caméra cachée c'est exactement ce qui va
se passer maintenant désabonner ont été
invités à participer à ce tournage
tous ont reçu un mail avec des consignes
tous sauf un
et c'est ce que vous allez découvrir
maintenant on va faire ensemble des
tests de questions réponses
il n'y a pas de piège et pas de trucs à
gagner ou de trucs à perdre c'est les
statistiques des réponses et des groupes
de réponses qui vont intéresser par la
suite donc si vous savez pas vous tentez
une réponse essayer de répondre quelque
chose parce qu'en fait vous n'avez pas
trop le choix puisque pour me répondre
vous allez devoir lever la main ok à
chaque réponse si je dirais est ce que
c'est un ou 2 6 et 2 lever la main je
considère que si la main est pas le vc 1
est-ce que ça c'est clair si vous il
avait la main c'est parfait j'ai
l'impression occasionné un mois j'ai vu
ton attitude et moi je sais que je
ramène pas en gros c'est les questions
que j'ai pris en masquant des chine
commission qui est sorti à quoi il ya un
mois tout le monde l'a vu ici de lever
la main ce qu'ils ont vu ok tout le
monde l'a vue près de personnes
la première question va voir si vous
avez vu le dernier épisode de matière
grise c'est ce qui me prouve votre
fidélité envers mon travail
pourquoi vous tournez détourner leurs
liens c'était très intéressé par cette
tâche là juste là dessus
quelle est la bible plus au sud entre
new york et rome levé la main pour new
york
si je lâche 1 kg de plomb ou 1 kg de
bois en même temps lequel arrivent au
sol en premier levé la main pour le bois
ce que quelqu'un des commentaires à
faire sur ma question c'est les deux
exactement et c'était très intéressant
pour moi d'avoir cette réaction n'a de
voir les yeux qu'ils faisaient en fait
il a dit si je lève pas c'est que je
réponds quand même et là des coups c'est
vraiment pas cool
ok c'était vraiment pour donner de la
matière que je commenterai plus tard
dans la vidéo soit tu aurais dit quoi
l'état c'est l'éducation en place par
les avancements
c'est assez respectueux combien de
tableau avant du van gogh de son vivant
un onze levé la main pour cet
intéressant j'ai regardé si le jeu on a
fait j'ai deux mille trucs comme une
pression incroyable je vois pourquoi là
du coup c'est simon qui vous donne la
réponse c'était ça commence par un 1 et
ça finit par un super
je dirais 1 1 ouais c'est ça c'est un
vendu qu'un seul tableau de son vivant
tout le reste ça a été post mortem est
ce que mon vrai prénom et fabien olicard
ou est-ce que j'ai pris un pseudo pour
la scène qui peut être que sur le prénom
opus sur le nom de famille évidemment
lever la main
si vous pensez que j'ai pris un pseudo
ce dos pour tout le monde
on passe à la question suivante c'est
tout à fait correct si je mélange du
jaune et du bleu jaune et bleu est ce
que j'obtiens du verre ou du orange levé
la main pour orange
quelle est l'origine du mot parmentier
est ce que c'est le nom de son inventeur
ou le fait qu'on mettait avant du jambon
de parme levé la main pour eux n'ont
levé la main pour inventeur combien de
face à un cube 4 ou 6 levé la main pour
4 ok on est bon pour tout va bien donc
qu'est ce qu'il vient de faire
exactement on vient de faire ce qu'on
appelle un test de conformité qui a
marché parfois et qui parfois n'a pas
fonctionné le test de conformité c'est à
dire que en réalité certains d'entre
vous avez les réponses en avance quand
je dis certains c'est tout le monde sauf
toi tu n'as pas levé la main sur le film
commission tout à l'heure oui tu vas pas
vu ok parce qu'il n'existe pas bah voilà
mais eux étaient au courant et je
voulais voir un petit peu si fabuleux
car c'est mon vrai nom je sais que ça se
sait où que ça se pressent mais je
voulais voir un petit peu si quand tout
le monde commence à lever la main s'il
n'y a pas de doute est ce que tout le
monde le bras bien la main là dessus sur
le pseudo toulon s'est dit oui à l'essai
un pseudo d'accord est-ce que tu
connaissais sincèrement la réponse sûre
si je mélange du jaune et du bleu
j'obtiens du verre ou du orange la
réponse du verte c'est un truc qui est
assez connue je me suis demandé si tu
connais les c'est la vraie réponse ou
pas du tout pas du tout aucune idée donc
comme ça aucune idée tu t'es dit je me
plie au groupe à ce moment là
complètement
c'est ça qui s'est passé ouais ok ok ça
c'est intéressant de se dire dans le
biais de conformité qu'on appelle aussi
ça le mouton de panurge en fait on suit
le groupe
si on sait pas s'il voit deux plutôt que
d'être al'inverse du groupe parce que
ton hasard ça aurait pu le dire aussi
je vais pas la main parce que je sais
pas et c'est vrai pour servir ce qui
m'importe c'est qu'on va avoir tendance
à suivre le groupe ok parmentier tu
savais pas que ça venait de son
inventeur donc pas du tout eh bien à
partir de maintenant ce sera le jambon
de parme pour toi mais c'est leur gré
dans le bain et donc pareil tard suivi
le groupe de la même manière dans cette
étape là tu t'es dit s'il avait la main
et lisa un peu ouais ouais ok et l'armée
temps je suis très curieux de savoir ce
qui s'est passé pour pourquoi t'as pas
levé la main sur le cube jeu le
visualiser way étudie à 604 en deux et
le fait que tout le monde lève la main
sata perturber une seconde pas non non
non je l'avais dans la tête
ok donc tu étais sûr de ta donné ok
c'est hyper intéressant parce que dans
des expériences plus longue qui ont été
faites mais qui prennent une heure et
demie et donc j'allais pas la reproduire
aujourd'hui quand on fait des tests
comme ça sur toutes les personnes et
donc il ya une ou deux personnes comme
ça qui est dans le test qui subit ce que
tu viens de subir il ya une heure de
questions normales et après au fur à
mesure il ya des fausses réponses qui
arrive qui sont parsemés est clairsemé
c'est assez passionnant parce que eux
ils viennent en plus pour quelque chose
à gagner un job quelque chose tu vois
donc il ya un vrai enjeu et le test du
cube a été fait qu'un test assez basique
personne ne se trompe pas ça et tu vois
les personnes se mettent à lever la main
sur quatre de manière contre nature et
donc je voulais voir si ça allait le
faire aussi rapidement j'en doutais un
peu mais mais de savoir que l'ade ça
t'es même pas traversé l'esprit je
trouve ça trop cool merci beaucoup en
tout cas que vous êtes prêté au jeu
c'était la raison principale de votre
venue ici parce que faire le test de
conformité que sur une personne c'était
moins marrant merci que s'est il passé
nous avons pu assister au bief de
conformité autrement appelée le syndrome
de panurge par rapport aux moutons qui
suivent le groupe
pourtant il faut que vous sachiez que le
groupe a répondu faut de manière
volontaire par rapport aux mails et aux
consignes qu'on leur avait donné avant
une seule personne parmi eux n'avaient
pas reçu le mail et les consignes la
vraie question c'est est ce que cette
personne a répondu faux parce qu'elle
n'avait pas la réponse
ou parce qu'elle a voulu se conformer au
groupe voici une étude de 2013 de
l'université de brown stone qui fait
suite aux travaux du psychologue solomon
asch dans les années 50 il semblerait
que ce soit l'insula situe au niveau du
cortex cérébral qui s'activerait
lorsqu'elle sent qu'on va se faire
rejeter du groupe auquel on appartient
l'insu la collecte des informations
émotionnel et sous la pression d'un
potentiel roger peut lâcher son opinion
de base pour se conformer au groupe une
autre étude de 2012 se référant à
condorcet à étudier le système de pensée
des votants mille personnes devant voter
pour un candidat ont été réunies ils
avaient tous un vote qui était clair et
défini dans leur tête juste avant qu'il
n'aille voter on leur a fait voir un
sondage et ce sondage montre est
volontairement le candidat opposé au
leur largement en tête
qu'est ce qu'il s'est passé 25% des
électeurs ont changé leur vote à la
dernière seconde en faveur du vote mis
en avant dans les sondages
une personne sur quatre avec un simple
sondage
cela démontre qu'il faut arrêter de
publier des sondages permanent qu'ils
soient réels ou trafic et ce n'est même
pas la question qu'on se pose
méfiez-vous du bief de conformité soyez
toujours libre de vos opinions et
réfléchissez toujours si vous avez un
raisonnement par rapport à vos pensées
ou par rapport au bout
[Musique]
il y aurait plus de 250 biais cognitif
différents ils sont intentionnels ou
mnésiques ou de jugement ou de
raisonnement ou simplement lié à votre
personnalité elle même
imprégné de vos caractéristiques
socioculturelles passons maintenant à
quelques questions vous n'avez peut-être
compris on va passer aux c'est à vous
donc le c'est à vous je vais vous poser
des questions et vous allez y répondre
dans les commentaires si vous êtes
honnêtes si vous n'êtes pas honnête dans
les commentaires dans dix secondes une
fois que vous avez la réponse
et quoi qu'il arrive simon va le vivre
en même temps que vous allez comme c'est
une vidéo sur les biais cognitifs et que
vous n'êtes pas idiots ou plutôt une
bonne nouvelle
abba fièrement un jugement personnel
mais oui non plus tout le temps le
confirme bien le déçoit pas quand vous
n'êtes pas idiots vous savez que c'est
des questions qui vont être piégé a les
pieds jambes parfois pas toujours mais
parfois donc je vous laisse à laps de
temps limité pour me pour formuler me
proposer une réponse très question
numéro une
je suis le frère de ces deux médecins
pourtant ces deux médecins ne sont pas
mes frères pourquoi eh bien je ne sais
pas c'est vrai à temps mais en même
temps les 10 secondes sont bien cramé
non il ya au bon moment quatre secondes
0 et moi sans une mauvaise perception du
temps compter sur une table attends quoi
je suis le frère de ces deux médecins
ouais bah ça c'est vrai et pourtant ces
deux médecins ne sont pas mes frères je
sais pas ça l'a énervé non parce que ces
gens simples est tout ouïe
vas-y smsr
ouais c'est de l'humiliation publique
quoi c'est ça le bon moi je t'avais
proposé pour 10 une question sur eux
oui d'accord oui cet accord d'accord
c'est mais en fait c'est un billet c'est
le biais genre est où maintenant on se
dit toujours un médecin c'est un homme
et toi en plus le pire c'est que par ton
métier tu travailles à l'imaginaire donc
tu as tout de suite eu des images de
médecins masculins dans ta tête et va
basculer pour avoir inverse
c'est quasi impossible c'est ça ben je
me trouvais super excuses n'aurait pas
trouvé mieux parce qu'ils ont la coupe
c'est un homme peut-il épousé la soeur
de sa veuve
waouh quoi s'ils allaient pas médecin un
homme
petit à petit les que j'ai épousé l'êtes
vous et la soeur de saveurs où les
pousse t aussi parcourir le plus futé
que tu veux épouser la soeur de sa veuve
de quoi mais de quoi déjà la question
est bizarre pourquoi ben parce que déjà
tu dis pourquoi faire ça et pourquoi l
aveugle qui l'amour à un homme un homme
politique épousé la soeur de sa veuve
dont équipe à un ben non parce qu'il est
mort
oui allez tu pourras jean coupé tout le
temps que je ne fais jamais vraiment le
trac
du coup va pas mettre ce passage là pour
le coupé mais c'est à tout ce que je dis
là faux couple est maintenant question 3
avant la découverte de l'everest
quel était le sommet le plus haut de la
terre l'everest joly est ce qu'on pourra
rallonger ce passage
émettre une réflexion de sa part même
laissé la passion de mon fils qui a 9
ans et qui a un livre comme ça avec une
tête d'hadji stein dessus vraiment fou
et avec des énigmes et il fait ça ah oui
avec les pièges et où j'étais bien entre
les deux quand même c'était assez
inspirons bêtise il mon inspiration
voitures et poubelles de l'inscrire dans
quelques années bien écrit la gr
clignote des flammes c'est fou noda il
monta recteur qui par ses copains si
elle a cette fois que dans le cirque et
non un fou à 30 à décoller j'adore
question 4 de retour dans le studio
oui un train alors là c'est toujours un
train part de paris vers marseille
ouais et roulent à 100 km ouais des
tranquilles oui oui petite vitesse et au
même instant un autre train part de
marseille pour aller vers paris donc
pendant le trajet inverse
mais lui roule à 200 km/heure au moment
où ils vont se croiser à l'est quel sera
le train le plus proche de paris
je te répète toutes les données ok ils
sont pas en grève déjà d'accord c'est ok
on mettrait bien donc là vas-y hockey
junior je fais ça bon jour l'une heures
je fais sa branche de paris celui qui
part de paris non paris marseille 100
km/heure marseille paris 200 kilomètres
heure en heure tu fais 200 km mais
didier awadi se croisent oui au moment
ils vont se rencontrer
moi j'ai fait il s'arrête au bout d'une
heure ce qui n'a aucun intérêt
d'ailleurs donne un temps de trajet non
et puis en plus ça fait prendre du
retard c'est hyper rouge depuis lors
c'est bien la dernière qui devait
devenir t'ai cherché à voulait pas
prendre des tickets à la tendance
ok oui donc au moment où ils se croisent
rue bonne passe on m'a dit des réponses
donc c'est donc le tract part de
marseille et c'est pas ça n'est pas bon
tv2 roy lewis croiser lequel est plus
proche de paris
super
voilà vous êtes super quoi moi je suis
allée horrible cette question un biais
de complexité ni plus ni moi c'est comme
tu as plein de dose et à l'impression
qu'il faut calculer des trucs et tu
oublies la donnée de base qui est bas 6
3/10 aux mêmes endroits dont ils sont
même endroit ils sont à mameui que paris
et de marseille
ils sont au même endroit si j'avais été
assez probantes était pas aussi reculé
c'est un fait plus que c'était moi alors
l'année dernier ton enfant il a quel âge
9 ans un enfant plus jeune que ton fils
il aurait sûrement la bonne réponse à la
prochaine question en tout cas plus
facilement qu'un adulte
ok il ya trois personnes qui sont dans
le désert ont déjà depuis trop longtemps
les yeux personnes qui sont dans le
désert elles sont à la file indienne
il n'y a aucun piège dans ce que je vais
te dire c'est à dire que tu as vraiment
un
l'autre qui est derrière lui dans le
même sens le ticket derrière lui dans le
même sens web mesure la même taille il
n'y a pas de piège comme ça le premier
dit devant moi je vois que le désert le
deuxième dit devant moi je vois la tête
d'un mec qui est de vendre et le
troisième dit devant moi je vois que le
désert comment c'est possible oui marche
à reculons
non ils sont vraiment il n'ya pas de
piège ont vraiment file indienne normal
ils mesurent 7 mètres 50
oui mais tous alors ils font tous la
même temps oui c'est vrai il ne perçoit
pas son nom il est constitué de telle
manière qu'ils ne qu'il ne voit pas les
humains mais non c'est possible mais
c'est possible
le premier ne voit que le désert de
deuxième le mais là on parle de gens qui
sont dans l'ordre - n'étaient pas en
train de me ferdinand résoudre plus
n'entend voilà pour que tu pense à tout
ça je te fais je te fais les bonnes âmes
je te fais des poneys ok jean-jacques
ils regardent par la gueule moi je vois
qu'elle disait ok bonjour jean qu'il est
honnête là c'est jean miro pesait sur la
sémer quand il a la même hauteur et 10
devant moi je vois un mec qui ressemble
à un marteau de juge
ok le ça complique beaucoup un mail ce
soit des juges des yeux
c'est pas faux le deuxième dit moi je
suis médecin ses deux frères et ça n'a
plus de sens il est bien derrière on
voit bien qu'il regarde bien la bonne
direction lui on n'a pas de problème
edit devant moi je vois que le désert
comment c'est possible
donc là le drame ils ne voient que le
désert il dit je ne vois plus le désert
comment c'est possible
qui a dit qu'il mentait c'est exactement
ça il ment tout simplement
et maintenant je vous laisse avec vous
même réfléchir pourquoi on se dit on va
pas remettre en cause l'honnêteté de ces
personnes parce que c'est une énigme
parce que c'est fabien parce que ceci
cela parce que mon cerveau est très
intelligent il a trouvé quelque chose
d'hyper rationnelle plutôt que cette
logique de base bayrou et quand tu fais
ce test là sur des enfants
louis sont jeunes puis disent c'est pas
vrai qu'est ce qu'il dit c'est
complètement faux et ils ont raison
c'est pas vrai mais ça c'est parce que
c'est ma conception du chu trop pure en
fait y pense
est ce qu'on pourrait appeler cette
vidéo tests de pureté avec simon astier
moi je pense que je fais des vues avec
ça
ouais je pense que là si tu passes le
test du des yeux du cerveau et du
marteau ouais ça veut dire que tu as le
corps pur way en 2016 duster benson à
déterminer les raisons pour laquelle
nous utilisons des biais cognitif en
permanence parce que c'est pas hasard
que notre cerveau utilise ces raccourcis
ou ses manières de retraités
l'information les raisons sont les
suivantes la première le cerveau reçoit
beaucoup trop d'informations d'un coup
la deuxième le cerveau veut donner du
sens aux informations qu'il reçoit
la troisième c'est que le cerveau doit
agir ou décider très rapidement et enfin
la quatrième c'est que le cerveau de
retenir des informations issues d'une
expérience pour potentiellement s'en
servir plus tard il en fait donc une
conclusion générale
mais il est loin le temps où devaient se
méfier d'un aliment parce qu'il
ressemblait de près ou de loin un autre
aliment qui nous avait rendu malade
précédemment il faut donc se méfier de
ses billets en analysant en permanence
les pensées qu'on a dans sa tête et
pourquoi elles viennent et si on jette
un bon regard sur le flot de pensées
qu'on a dans le cerveau on pourrait
alors trier l'information de base
la vraie pensée bien avant qu'elles
soient conclues par les biais cognitif
merci à tous les participants merci à
toute l'équipe merci à fanny à la
production à loïc à la réalisation et un
grand merci à simon astier qui a sauvé
ce tournage en remplaçant en invité à la
dernière minute c'était super chouette
de sa part d'ailleurs vous pouvez aller
le voir jouer au théâtre michel à partir
du 3 décembre où il va interpréter le
discours le lien est dans la description
vous pouvez cliquer cette vidéo la
partagez vous abonner c'est gratuit
évidemment pour ne pas rater les
prochains épisodes et les précédents
épisodes de matière grise sont dans la
description alors pouvons nous améliorer
notre dépendance au bief sommes nous
vraiment maîtres de nos raisonnements
pouvons nous changer notre système de
pensée nous aurons la réponse à tout
cela et bien plus dans les prochains
épisodes de matière grise
à très bientôt ciao